I remember working with a client
recently and she said to me I'm finding
it challenging to get clients and I said
to her I want you to get me 50 notes
what she didn't know is that if she
wants to do this exercise properly she
would never get to 50 notes what you're
about to hear is an interview between me
and my friend Simon Alexander Ong I know
Simon quite well so I gave him a bit of
a hard time around this because I think
often it's easy to view coaches and life
coaches and stuff as being a bit scammy
and like what the hell is this kind of
it's an unregulated industry anyone can
become a coach but as you'll hear in the
conversation like just Simon's responses
to all of my attempts at giving him a
hard time are just so good what did
success mean to me and what sort of
impact did I want to have in the world
and after searching in different areas
and Fields I ended up coming back to the
fact that I really enjoyed helping
people Simon has just released this book
energize which is genuinely really good
make the most of every moment I'm just
going to read you out a little bit of
his bio Simon Alexander Ong is a
personal development entrepreneur coach
and public speaker his clients are from
all walks of life but they share one
trait they all believe that the greatest
invest assessment you can make is in
yourself the first sale which few of us
actually focus on is selling ourselves
to ourselves in this conversation we
basically talk about the idea of what
it's like to be a personal development
entrepreneur and a coach I went away
from the conversation like genuinely so
inspired because I was just so impressed
by the way Simon responded to all of the
issues that I tried to throw at him so
if you could pick five to six
individuals Dead or Alive who could be
your counsel who would they be I hope
you enjoyed this conversation between me
and Simon Alexander Ong at the moment
according to the YouTube analytics 81 of
you who are watching this on YouTube
have not yet hit the Subscribe button
and so if you're for example in the now
81 of people who are watching this on
YouTube but who are not subscribed to
the channel I would love it if you could
do so and would be awesome to get that
number down to 50 and it would be cool
to get like 50 50 sub non-sub ratio just
just for fun right Simon thank you so
much for coming on the podcast um we've
known each other for a couple years now
first through the Mastermind that we
were on in zoom and then knowing each
other in real life and one thing that
I've always wanted to ask you is
um around your I guess guess your
tagline like the the labels that you
introduce yourself with at least in the
book Simon Alexander Ong is a personal
development entrepreneur coach and
public speaker and initially I would
like and and this would have been like
two years ago when we first met over
Zoom I wasn't really sure what that
meant and in my mind like coach was
associated with some kind of
artist kind of vibe like what even is a
professional coach and over time I you
know personal development entrepreneur I
think that's kind of what I am now and
my budget artist like yeah and so I'd
love to start with like how how did you
end up becoming a coach like what even
is a coach like how how did we get here
I was like yourself out here I didn't
know what a coach was in terms of
professional coaching for me my
understanding went as far as Sports you
know if you were going into coaching you
were going to coach a sports team or you
were going to train to go in a field and
perform at your best I didn't know you
could have it in the world of
professional work I actually had my
first exposure to coaching I didn't
really know it was coaching at the time
when I was at University so while most
students went to work at a local
retailer or department store I actually
met a guy called Peter Harrison he was
doing a talk at the London School of
economics and he had just quit his job
at Goldman Sachs to start a career
coaching business and he he came up to
me and said Simon I like the way you
present yourself and I like the way that
you come across would you be interested
in teaching students how to get a job in
the city I.E how can they interview
better how can they present in order to
wow the people in the room and I I said
well how much you paying and he offered
me good money and so on the side of
studying at University I started helping
students get into University how much
are we talking so not not enough that
was life changing but but enough to
upkeep my student lifestyle okay so to
speak and I continued that into the
world of Finance I did it on the side
while initially I did it for the money I
started to continue doing it even though
I didn't need to do it when I started in
the world of Finance purely because I
got enjoyment and fulfillment from
seeing people send me a message back on
the phone saying Simon I just landed
that offer Simon I got my third job
offer but I never knew that I could
pursue a career in that I thought it was
just a nice way to make some pocket
money and then of course the financial
crisis happened and that prompted me to
ask some deep questions about my future
because I'd only gone into a world of
Finance because I felt that was what
would make me successful so I started
asking myself things such as what did
success mean to me and what sort of
impact did I want to have in the world
and after searching in different areas
and Fields I ended up coming back to the
fact that I really enjoyed helping
people I was that sort of person early
where people when they had a challenge
or dilemma or big question that they
wanted perspective about they would come
to me but I didn't know I could make
money from it until I went to a two-day
event it was all about coaching it was
about how you could get qualifications
to apply this skill into helping people
you worked with and that's really where
it began so it is it kind of like being
a teacher but you're not teaching like
maths or history you're teaching
what like yes I would be careful with
the the definition here I think when we
teach we're more of a mentor okay uh so
for example if I wanted to develop my
speaking I might seek out somebody who
is far more experienced to me in the
public speaking world and so he or she
would be my mentor because I could learn
a lot from them they could guide me they
could teach me coaching is less about
telling you what to do and more about
guiding you back to what you already
know through the power of questions you
know often we we hear the saying that
goes want a better answer ask a better
question and so coaching is all about
asking the right question in the right
moment to uncover the path forward for
your client
okay so who is the sort of person that
might have a coach or might hire you as
their coach sure so in the past it was
probably
exclusively in the domain of c-suite
executive so people at the higher
echelons of management
nowadays it's become far more accessible
so we're we're looking at coaching
generally then it's people who want to
move ahead in life people who have an
exciting future in their mind but I
don't quite know how to get there and
they need a better challenge you know if
we are the only one holding us
accountable then likely we can
procrastinate we can move the goal posts
but when there is a coach we're working
with we are challenged to become better
than who we were yesterday and
our perspective is questioned and we're
forced to see things from a different
perspective to give an example I
remember working with a client recently
and she said to me I'm finding it
challenging to get clients for my
business and I said to her how many
conversations have you had in the last
few weeks and she said just a few and I
said that's where we're going to begin
and my challenge to you is in the next
90 days I want you to get me 50 notes
get me 50 no's that was her challenge me
as a coach I was holding her accountable
for this challenge but what she didn't
know is that if she wants to do this
exercise properly she would never get to
50 news
because what happens is the more we put
ourselves out there the more chances for
that yes and I remember she dropped me a
WhatsApp uh shortly after and said Simon
I don't think I'm gonna get to 50 notes
and part of me was smiling in my head
and I said tell me why and she said I've
just got my sixth yes
and so that's part of what coaching is
about it's to believe in the person
often before they can believe in
themselves and it is a gift to have
someone in your corner like that hmm
how does one find a coach
and like so like
I'm for example know a bunch of people
who are like um you know maybe they've
got a job that they don't particularly
enjoy like it's fine and they're holding
it out until the next promotion or
whatever and they know they want to
maybe start a side hustle start a
business on the side they don't really
know where to start and it's like
and they'll come to me for advice being
like where do I start and I'm like
ugh
um I mean have you read the four I work
week and then I fastly I mean I can
recommend a few books but I've I've
never once thought oh you should hire a
coach hmm um because like in my any even
though I've had coaches for the last two
years it that that's not a thing that
connects whereas if someone came into me
and said how do I get better at tennis I
was like hire a tennis coach obviously
that's just a no-brainer um yeah so
where does one get started if one might
might want to find a coach how does that
work sure well the great thing about
today's environment is that we can find
a coach for a multitude of different
platforms so whether it is online
whether it is for a referral an
introduction or simply hopping onto
Google now as with anything before you
invest in a coach it's important to get
a feel for what that person is like and
that's why you should seek out an
experience and that is why when I when I
work with younger coaches who are
looking to build their business I always
say
the greatest gift you can give people
before they sign up to you as a client
is to give them an experience of what
coaching is about because coaching is
very hard to explain to someone who has
never gone through the experience and so
when you can invite somebody to have a
powerful conversation that's when they
walk out of the room and said
I need coaching so is that like a sort
of free free trial kind of thing like
exactly exactly it's what you give them
experience of what coaching can have on
them and the actions that they take okay
so it's like when I went to the gym and
I was like I'm looking for a personal
trainer they were like oh we'll set you
up with a free session with one of our
guys and if you like it you can talk
about it totally it's like a try on I
mean if you look at business in general
nearly every business starts with a
trial you know if you sign up to a
online platform chances that would be
the 30-day free trial and then your
upsell to become a become a member with
a subscription this is how it works if
you like the experience what happens is
you're more likely to want to invest in
it but it's very difficult if you
haven't gone through that and when I
first started building my coaching
practice I just went out to as many
events as I could to meet people and
when I heard that they were going for a
challenge or there was an opportunity
for me to help I simply said to them
what are you doing next week would you
be interested in having a powerful
conversation together a powerful
conversation and that's it I just
stopped it there and if it was a year s
we would then have a meeting at my
office yeah and we would just dive deep
to really understand what was going in
their mind so is it that like any kind
of challenge or is it like a domain
specific is it like oh I'm struggling to
generate leads for my business or my
relationship is falling apart or I'm
struggling to make Facebook ads like
what what level of tactical versus
um abstract are we talking sure so for
me it would always begin at the broad
level uh Because unless you can address
the broad issues there's no point
focusing on the Tactical okay because
you can give someone all the Tactical
know-how but if they don't have the
Baseline energy or the mindset or the
resources in place they're not going to
put into action you know we can just we
can go into Google we can go into
YouTube there's all the Tactical stuff
on there but the thing is very few
people apply it now there has to be a
reason why we don't apply it and so for
me to tackle things at that level
because everything just flows from from
that point
okay so let's say you were to come up to
me at one of these events and so I'm I'm
not I'm not going to use myself right
now as an example because I think it's
it's potentially unrelatable to both
people but like let's say it's
I've you've you've come to me at an
event and maybe I am a year into my
full-time job as a doctor and I'm not
really sure if it's for me and you and I
are talking and how how would that
conversation at the event go like sure
so it depends chances are when we meet
guaranteed the first question you will
probably ask me because we don't know
each other would be Simon what do you do
yeah now
how I respond to that is by giving what
I call a trailer so when you go to the
cinema before you have the main feature
film you have a series of around five or
six trailers a trailer is very powerful
because most of us respond with a title
so I'm an accountant I'm an engineer I'm
an entrepreneur
unfortunately when we respond with a
title humans tend to box that into
certain judgments so if I say I'm an
accountant most people might think I'm
boring or how can I move on to the next
person why did I get stuck in this
conversation so I would first respond
with a trailer something like everything
I do
is to awaken people's imagination of
what is truly possible so they can live
a better story
now what happens or a variant of that
and now what happens is that chances are
they get curious yeah like well tell me
more okay and that is the purpose
because when I deliver a trailer okay
they now want to watch the full film so
in this case the film is my product or
service they get interested do you do
you not feel like
how did you get okay with just saying
that completely sincerely like this is
one of the things I like about you like
uh and in the book as well just a lot of
the stuff like where the cynical glance
could be seen as a bit like woo
especially the whole energy thing and
you're just so sincere about it like
were you always like this or did you
have to overcome the cringe response to
asking a question of what do you do
rather than saying I'm a coach with the
trailer sure I I think to be fair I've
never I've never seen as cringe purely
because I think that
for me and something I share in the book
there's always two sales to happen the
second sale is selling ourselves to
other people so whether that is getting
investment for your business selling an
idea to your colleagues or selling
yourself in your business the first sale
which few of us actually focus on is
selling ourselves to ourself and until
we can sell ourselves to ourselves of
course things are going to feel cringe
yeah but if actually you're coming from
a place of authenticity and you believe
that you have that value to off you have
that value to offer yeah for me it
doesn't come across as cringe and so
when I started to speak that it came
from a place of belief uh you know I was
inspired actually to talk about trailers
in such a way from from someone I saw in
America on the speaking circuit and when
he was asked what do you do the way he
responded came across so natural but it
was him
no one else could say it in the way he
did it and I think that's where
authenticity comes from he said I have
been saving the world from boredom since
before you were born
now I'm interested tell me more in fact
all he was was a public speaker but the
way he presented it got me interested
yeah
nice it's like a title and a thumbnail
on a YouTube video almost where
you kind of have to package it in a way
that makes people want to click and want
to find out more and some people might
be like clickbait but actually you want
to toe the line between you want to be
sufficiently intriguing so as to Warrant
someone's attention definitely because
if you just describe what the thing is
about No One's Gonna care and we have to
we have to embrace that fact you know I
read in the in in the garden a few years
ago that the average attention span for
a human was eight seconds yeah what they
did is they got people in the room they
gave them tasks and they would throw
distractions their way to see how long
it would take before they would stop
doing the task and focus on the
distraction and they found that average
to be eight seconds
what was more interesting was the fact
that the average attention span for
goldfish was nine seconds so that tells
us two things on the one hand is if our
attention span is that short how do we
manage our own attention and focus
secondly how do we get the attention
from other people whether that is
customers audiences that we're looking
to yeah speak to and that's where some
of these things come in handy the
psychology of an audience how do we
engage with people so they want to
listen so they want to ask questions
they want to be curious okay so well I'm
sure we'll definitely come around to the
how do we manage our own attention but
let's go back to this I'm where you and
I are at the convention and I ask you
Simon what do you do uh what What's your
trailer to that sure so one of the
versions I might say is everything I do
is to awaken people's imagination of
what is truly possible so they can live
a better story now once we've gone past
the introductions then I'd be like oh
okay
tell me more does that mean yeah and so
what I do is I continue telling stories
because what I've understood is that
we're humans which means we make
purchasing decisions not based on facts
or figures but based on emotion okay and
so most of us when they then say tell me
more how do you do what you do we jump
straight into Logistics we go well we
would meet twice a month we would look
at deers we would meet here we can do it
virtual
people don't care about that
yes at the end that's important but at
this early stage I jump into more
stories so they might say how do you do
what you do Simon tell me more I would
say something like well let me tell you
about one of my clients Emma who came to
me about six months ago now when she
first approached me this is where she
was at that moment of her life now just
yesterday she got an email from the
United Nations inviting her to speak at
a conference in Madrid something she
could never imagine that she could
achieve in her lifetime so what's going
through their mind now is wow Simon can
you do to me what you did to Emma
so what they're doing is they're putting
themselves into that story
understanding that the role of a coach
is as a guide
is to unlock their own hero potential
and they see that in the stories that we
share
okay
so at this point I'm thinking
I'm I'm putting myself in the shoes of
Emma and I'm thinking huh I'm I feel
like I don't really know what to do oh
yeah I'd love to get invited by the
United Nations or whatever that might
look like and then I'd probably ask okay
so what does that what does that look
like how do you work with Emma
definitely so what I then do is when I
speak to the person in front of me I try
and understand what is important to them
because again everyone has a different
version of success okay so they might
say well I want to do something that is
more fulfilling I want to have more
freedom in my life and then I get even
more curious because the whole point of
this conversation is to unpackage what
is in their minds okay think of it like
if you've ever seen a Sherlock Holmes TV
series or movie yeah before Sherlock
Holmes dives into his mind to figure out
the mystery or the answer to a crime
yeah he sits the person in an armchair
opposite him yep and he simply asked
questions to unpackage what is in their
mind yeah so my next question may be
well what does freedom mean to you what
does freedom look like what does success
mean specifically yeah so once I get all
of this data this is just data a
gathering at this point then
I can then lead them to that powerful
conversation by saying what would be
possible for you when you have that
freedom
when you're able to choose how you spend
your time when you're doing something
that fulfills you and brings you Joy
where you can wake up every Monday
morning excited by the week and not
dreading it what would be possible for
you and then we move the conversation
into the land of possibility and that's
what energizes them and then I simply
say would you like to explore more of
this and have a conversation about how
to begin making this work
shh
nice this is like I I'm I'm feeling
myself getting like I sort of having a
very cynical view of it at the start and
then being like Oh actually you know
when you ask me what do I what do I
think of success like what does freedom
mean to me actually
some good questions uh and I think
one of the things I find about about
coaching which is great is that a lot of
the
the questions and stuff that a coach
would ask
are like a little bit weird in like a
normal social setting like you wouldn't
just over dinner ask someone so what's
your biggest challenge right now or
something like that and yet I know
people who do that and I've started
doing that with people now and it's just
kind of interesting because it gets
straight to like an interesting
conversation Beyond it's so powerful
because I think that if we go
back decades before coaching was the
industry it is today this is what
friends did you know when you met up and
you didn't have all of these
distractions of today screens technology
work and so on when you met up and had a
coffee with a friend you literally got
curious about people uh you know I did
the exact same thing with a friend
recently and she she loved the
conversation we only met at a networking
event a couple of months ago and we met
for coffee and she told me she was in
the process of writing a book and so I
got curious I said how long have you
been writing the book for and she said
it's been about five or six years and
I'm just starting to get through the
process now
and my natural next question was what
has stopped you and now we were kind of
entering a coaching conversation here
but it was very natural it wasn't weird
questions coming up it was just coming
from place of curiosity and by the end
of that conversation she said wow
you know I'm very inspired now and I
can't wait to show you the progress I
will be making in the next couple of
months and so she knew the answers it
was just about discovering the courage
to take action and sometimes this is
what coaching can do it can give people
that space to reflect yeah to
connect the dots which we all have you
know we're all collecting dots all the
time through conversation through
watching YouTube videos listen to
podcasts learning from other people yeah
however we don't give ourselves the
space to connect those dots and that's
what's most important there's no point
collecting dots if you don't have the
space to connect them
if you don't have this so okay so in my
in my example of you know we've met at
this this convention I I'm working
full-time as a doctor Simon in 60 hour
weeks like like what do you mean have to
have the space I don't have any any
space in my life well that would be the
first place we would begin then is to
get some space back okay because if you
have zero space how can you focus on
what matters most yeah whatever we work
on whatever you want to do in life you
simply don't have the time to do that
and so you've got to understand that you
have to make some sacrifices for what
you want otherwise the very thing that
you want becomes what you sacrifice and
so to remind people to reflect on that
Vision they have for their life you know
we can be energized in a moment I call
this feeling positive or positively
charged but there's no point being
positively charged if there's no
magnetic charge of a vision that is
compelling and exciting nice once you've
got a vision that is compelling and
exciting you've got a magnetic charge in
place that's what pulls us forward okay
many of us simply don't know what it is
we do want
yeah so this is a thing that I've been I
have been coming up against when when
making certain YouTube videos about this
where a lot of the comments are like
okay you're saying like you could make
money from your passions well I don't
know what my passion is like I don't I
don't actually know what I want like how
would someone listen to this or watching
this start to approach that question of
how do I figure out what I actually want
sure and
it's a very it's a very important
question because a lot of people I speak
with say to me Simon I'm not taking
action or executing because I don't know
what my purpose is and so how do I know
I'm taking action on the right things
that will lead me to where I want to be
my response to that is none of us wake
up one morning and know exactly what we
want to do for the rest of our lives
it would be great if that happens but
it's only in the Hollywood film in
reality what happens is that we get
given Clues we get given insights we are
given experiences that nudges towards
where it is that we were meant to be now
the best place to begin is instead of
asking yourself what is my passion and
what is my purpose is to Simply ask
yourself what am I most curious about
right now oh right now what am I most
curious about now
here's why it's a powerful question
because asking yourself what my purpose
and passion is puts you in the future
but let's be honest none of us can
predict the future none of us know if
the future we want is actually going to
manifest I mean how many people had the
coveted pandemic in their business plans
no one
so bringing it back to the present and
asking a softer question what am I most
curious about now grounds you in the
present and allows you to focus on
following those those truths those
wisdoms that we have inside of us
what do you mean by curious so I'll give
an example yeah
my journey into coaching wasn't because
I woke up one morning said you know I
want to coach and speak for the rest of
my life okay I I was in the financial
industry yeah I was disillusioned I was
feeling unfulfilled yeah and so my
curiosity at the time was
What would life be like if I worked for
myself and I didn't work for other
people okay now that Curiosity led me to
read business books uh to watch shows
about entrepreneurship that led me into
my first business venture which didn't
succeed but again I would never have
started it without that Curiosity that
led me to get involved in some Community
projects to be exposed to different
people in different environments which
led me to my second business which
didn't work out but in that second
business led me to people that guided me
to this coaching event that happened one
weekend that weekend became the
beginning of my journey but it was
curiosity that created those Stepping
Stones now here's why it's important
whenever we begin A New Path we don't
get given the entire map up front
that map
opens up as we take steps forwards
and the more steps that we take the more
of that map that is opened up to us it's
like putting together a jigsaw puzzle
yeah you know you can't see it straight
away but the more pieces you put
together the quicker that picture begins
to form and that's what we've got to
trust trust in the process take one step
forward each day and imagine a year from
now where you could be 365 steps forward
so
we you mentioned that there's this sort
of magnetic field of vision
so then by Vision do you just mean what
is the next step or like how how far are
we planning here sure so
there's an element of having a balancer
you you have to have a vision to give
you context for today otherwise you can
take any action because you don't know
where it's going to lead or where you
want to be yeah so the vision is
something that is compelling enough for
you to want to take some action okay now
when we look at the action piece it's
not about taking big steps it's then
about taking small steps so thinking big
and starting small that's the balance
that we have to get yeah now the
thinking big piece is what activates our
our emotions yeah when we think about
something that we want to achieve in our
lifetime that is what creates that
emotional pull when we look at a present
it's what is the one small step that is
in my control that I can take to date
that's it just focus on today one small
step that will contribute to that Vision
starting to take shape and in tomorrow
ask yourself the same question what is
one small step that I can take today
that will move me forward so that's the
balance we have to have is do we have to
have Clarity of a vision that is
magnetic in nature but also to just take
small steps forward not to be
overwhelmed with how many steps there is
to go yeah but just on the present
moment
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from this episode to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal now heal is great
because I've been a customer of huel for
the last six years and also we've got an
interview with Julian Hearn who is the
founder of huel on this podcast so you
can check that out it'll be on the
YouTube channel and on the Spotify page
and that wasn't a fantastic masterclass
in entrepreneurship but anyway we're
talking about heal because heel is a
fantastically complete meal so if you're
like me and you have a fairly busy life
and you don't necessarily make the time
to shop and cook and prep and wash up
like a healthy meal at home which is
obviously ideal then the nice thing
about Hill is that it's a great
alternative to an unhealthy cereal or an
unhealthy takeaway meal for example I
particularly like the heel black edition
because this is high protein and lower
carb so for 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein and so this is
absolutely fantastic for workout days
where I'm trying to get my 160 180 grams
of protein in and it's also great
because the high protein helps me stay
full for a lot longer take my two scoops
of the Black Edition powder I like the
banana Edition and The Salted Caramel
Edition I'll mix it up in my NutriBullet
blender thing with water and maybe a
little bit of milk sometimes and then
I'll just sip on that while I'm at my
desk and that will get me the
appropriate level of protein that I need
it'll get me a decent chunk of
carbohydrates and fibers and fat and
also 26 different vitamins and minerals
which are generally very good for the
body it's also very reasonably priced
like if you work it out it comes out to
one pound 68 per meal ish which is about
400 calories and that's way cheaper than
an alternative would be if you were
ordering takeout for example so if that
sounds up your street and you would like
a nutritionally complete and affordable
and healthy option for some of your
meals then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt and also a
free shaker bottle thing with your first
order I still use my t-shirt it's great
it's a nice elastic key it fits
reasonably well it makes me look kind of
hinged so you can check that out
heel.com forward slash deep dive so
thank you so much heel for sponsoring
this episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by trading212. now people
ask me all the time for advice about
investing because I've made a bunch of
videos about it on the YouTube channel
and my advice for most people is
generally invest in Broad stock market
index funds which is exactly what you
can do completely for free with trading
212. it's a great app that lets you
trade stocks and funds and ETFs and
foreign exchange if you really want to
and one of the great things about the
app is that if you're new to the world
of investing you can actually invest
with fake money you don't have to put
real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading two into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone else has is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you the app also lets you
Auto invest which is a great thing
because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started when investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali at the
checkout that will give you a totally
free share worth up to 100 pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading
212 into your respective App Store so
thank you so much trading212 for
sponsoring this episode okay so this
seems a bit some some contradictory and
it's probably just like my
misunderstanding of it so you're saying
that
you can't just wake up and figure out
your passion and purpose but you should
still have a vision definitely so we'll
call the difference between sort of
purpose and vision sure so with the
vision is when you start to be curious
about what it is that interests you okay
that starts to feed into a vision now
the point of having a vision it's not
you can have a hundred percent Clarity
yet okay but you have to have some idea
so you might begin with your vision
simply being Freedom that's it one word
my vision is to have freedom okay so
let's say I'm working full-time at the
doctor 60 hour weeks and my vision is
like ah you know what I'd love to live a
life where you know even if I was just
working three days a week I'd have so
much time I'd be able to do this exactly
so it starts off with just that okay now
you take some small steps forward it
could be simple as starting to read
different material yeah it could be
going to different events now what
happens is that as you begin exposing
yourself to new environments that
energize you that Vision starts to
expand now you begin getting more
specific
Freedom by doing what
freedom is a lifestyle where I can do X
now you start to fill in more of that
puzzle okay and then you take more steps
forward of course you start to fill in
more division okay so the vision has to
begin with something and it can be even
one word we've used Freedom here but
whatever word means something to you
about what you want to work towards if
you take small steps forward that's
where you get more clarity that Vision
starts to expand you start to get more
clear on what is in that vision for you
Okay so
I wonder if we can almost just like role
play this with my with my doctor
scenario so we're having a powerful
conversation you've asked me what I'm
curious about and I'm thinking
you know what I want to say I I feel
like
I'm so burnt out from this job I feel
like I used to be curious about things I
was super interested in like learning
learning to play the guitar and getting
better music theory and I love the idea
of
um maybe starting a podcast one day
where I I interview people because I've
been listening to the Tim Ferrer show a
bit and I think it's kind of cool and I
listen to it on my commute but I just
like I feel like I don't really have the
time to to do any of it so
I guess that's what I'm curious about
sort of a little bit of music a little
bit of like the podcast stuff sure but I
feel like I just don't really have the
space in my life too well my first
question to you would be what is
important about starting a podcast
hmm what is important about starting a
podcast
I guess for me I like the idea of
learning from interesting people
um I feel like the reason I went into
medicine partly was this idea of
lifelong learning but now that I'm in it
like you know especially at the junior
level that I'm at a lot of it is like
following guidelines and it's it's it's
honestly not that intellectually
stimulating I know that eventually when
I specialize in stuff it will be but
like at least right now I feel like I'm
an admin monkey doing admin work
and I feel like I'm not really learning
anything beyond beyond the first few
weeks so I just I I think that's a
really cool way and when you have a
podcast like I know that lets you just
meet people because then you can say do
you want to be on my podcast rather than
hmm uh just do you want to have a chat
and so that's why I I've kind of had
vaguely had this idea in the back of my
mind but I'm I I'm not really sure if
they'll go anywhere um
and What would life be like
if
you could focus and prioritize lifelong
learning
if I could focus and prioritize lifelong
I feel like life would be a lot better I
feel like if I again if I had if I had
the time for it in my in in my life I I
feel like every week every month I'd be
you know because I I like I like to read
a bit when I when I have the time and
there's always new things that I want to
want to learn more about and that gives
me a lot of fulfillment how important is
it for you to start making steps towards
making that a reality on a scale of one
to ten oh
question
um
honestly right now is probably like a
two because I just I can't see anyway
like I know that for the next two years
I've got to grind out this foundation
training and maybe at that point then
I'll have time in my life to if I take a
break but then I know if I take a break
then I'm not gonna have a salary coming
in and so I I keep on coming up against
that barrier of I I know I'm in this
career path I know I need the money to
pay rent but like I just don't feel like
I feel like once I have the time then of
course I can do all the lifelong
learning hmm
how long have you been saying that to
yourself when I have the time
honestly since for the last like eight
years ever since I got into med school I
was like
when I get out then I'll have time to do
this and now that I'm working and think
when I when I take my break then I'll
have time to do this so I've been
telling myself that for for like eight
years at this point eight years I'm
curious if you were to have taken
some small steps eight years ago where
do you think it could be now oh
yeah you got me um probably
living a life that I'm I feel more
infused by I guess
um although even then it's it's
hard to say because like this this
career path that I'm in feels like it's
you know I'm on this I'm on this
conveyor belt and I have to like but I
guess I guess that's what I've been
telling myself that I have to keep on
taking that next step within medicine
itself which feels like it doesn't
really leave enough time for for the
things that I want to do I'm curious you
said you've been telling yourself is
that really you telling yourself
hmm
is it really me telling myself
I I think it's
always that someone else telling you
that inside
as in is it because that's been
imprinted into you by an outside
influence
is that really what it is you want to do
oh yeah
that's a good point I think like ever
since I even entertained the thought of
going to medical school everyone around
me has been telling me how difficult
it's going to be and how tough it is and
you know obviously during school I had
to grind super hard to get all these
like grades and stuff and when I was at
University in medical school suddenly
from day one it was like okay well
you've got to continue grinding because
it's specialty applications and
Foundation applications and it's like at
every stage I've been so focused on how
do I take that next box
that to me it's always felt like oh of
course I don't have time in my life I'm
a medical student now I I have to be
grinding all the time to to pass my
exams and stuff Here's a thought for you
and I think it's something
you know deep down
it's not a question of time
it's a question of whether it is
important to you you and I know that if
something is really important to you you
will make time for it
if I was to recommend your Netflix show
that everyone is watching at the moment
that is getting all the attention in the
Press I have no doubt you will find time
to watch it
so now I feel deep down you know
yourself it's not question of time it's
the question of importance how important
is it for you to do something that is
more fulfilling to live life for you and
not for others
damn I've never thought of that
um
now that you mention it it's yeah it's
pretty important it's pretty it's pretty
important I would I would love that for
that to be my life so my challenge to
you
and I don't know where this is going to
go after this but let's say we were to
touch base in a week from now what would
be one thing that you would commit to
doing between now and next week
however small
to start making what you've shared with
me a reality
hmm
okay
I guess I could
like for example I like this idea of
starting a podcast I think it would be
it would be cool so I guess I could
watch a YouTube video about how to start
a podcast and
um
start making a plan of what that could
look like
I'm noticing the word could a lot
I'm going to rephrase the question again
what will you do between now and next
week
I will watch a YouTube video about how
to start a podcast and I will make a
plan for what my podcast is going to
look like great let's get specific get
your calendar out when exactly will you
be blocking out time to watch that
YouTube video
okay so I've got a shift tomorrow and
the day after but oh I've only got a
half day and you know on Sunday so
Sunday
finish work at 1pm get home by 2 I think
lunch two to three okay three to four
p.m I will make time to watch that that
YouTube video fantastic and in the
second part to what you shared when will
you make plans
to move forward so you said watch
YouTube video and make some plans to
make that a reality when would be a good
time to make some plans for you good
question
um so I'm actually free that rest of the
afternoon so three to four pm I'll watch
that YouTube video and find a bunch of
videos to figure out what the next steps
are and then four to five pm I'll
commit to making to making a plan of
what my podcast is going to look like
amazing you know what I can't wait to
speak to you again next week and hear
how you've got on with watching those
YouTube videos and to see what you've
put together in that plan
nice that's so good how how did you
learn how to do that I would love to be
able to do that the thing is a secret if
you've noticed a lot of coaches when
they first start yeah is we're seeking
Bank of questions what are the questions
I should ask which is the right question
to ask in the right moment the truth is
the best question comes in the moment
the best question can only present
itself when we listen to what the other
person is saying because
once we begin stepping into that
person's world so what I was doing if
you were noticing I was Data Gathering
yeah and as I was Data Gathering it
allowed me to step into your world a bit
more to see the world that you were
living in and so it helped me to
understand where to push where to
challenge but also where to question and
that can only be built through practice
as with any skill to master something
we've got to practice it
nice okay so coming back to your um so
you're working in finance and you were
kind of helping people get into jobs in
the city that's fairly analogous to what
I was doing in medicine and helping
people get into med school and that was
for me how I realized oh I actually
really enjoy teaching teaching is kind
of fun it's this cool thing to do
um oh and so you said that you did this
two-day coaching coaching thing like
what what was that like sure so it was
won by a company called a coaching
Academy I went in there just like
yourself earlier I was a bit skeptical I
went in there thinking what am I going
to really learn in two days the Saving
Grace was the fact that it was free and
the only thing that it would cost me was
my time by the end of that weekend I
remember coming home to to my wife and I
said to her I want to sign up to this
course it's so exciting and I can't wait
to learn more about how to apply these
coaching skills into the lives of other
people
and two years later I finished I was
balancing this alongside a nine to five
I finished with with two qualifications
and then I started to apply that in the
conversations that I had with people and
before long I started to build my
coaching practice and then from there
things started to happen organically I
went from Dad into speaking being
invited onto Sky News and the BBC to
talk about my work and then more
recently signing a book they were
penguin to write not only about my
journey but what I've learned through
the work that I've done with clients and
also speaking to audiences from
corporate to the public
one criticism that some people have of
the coaching industry is that it's
unregulated and anyone can just call
themselves a coach and you see these 18
year old influencers who suddenly become
life coaches like what's what's going on
in that side of the industry and I yeah
I guess you're sort of in it so you can
sure yeah
I think this is why it goes back to
getting an experience with a coach first
before you agree to do anything because
as you said it's one of those Industries
where anybody can be a coach I mean you
can set up your social media account in
a couple of hours you can call yourself
a coach and you can start marketing what
you do
but for me when I'm looking for a coach
or Mentor I want to see somebody's track
record I also want to have an experience
with someone so I know what they're
capable of
a lot of people can read books and think
they're a great coach straight away
without any practice or experience it's
not just in the coaching world it's in a
lot of different businesses we can start
something and
people find it very difficult to tell
the difference because we have an
abundant of services in in in the board
that we're in at the moment and so
for me
it's important to be careful about who
you trust in the online world
but also what we want to do is to look
at how they're focusing on themselves as
well because as a coach we can only lead
and take people as far as we have gone
ourselves and if we're not improving if
we're not putting ourselves out there if
we don't even have a coach or Mentor
ourselves how can we help those that we
want to help and so again research is is
such a critical component of this but
it's a valid question Ali because I
often get asked
how important qualifications are as part
of becoming a coach because in a world
in which as you said anybody can become
a coach how important of a role do
qualifications play I got my
qualifications after starting for a
couple of years but it's a tricky one
and how I tend to respond to this is
that what is more important is the
results that somebody has got because
you might have somebody who has all the
qualifications under the sun
they're great at what they do
but
they don't have the experience they
haven't built a successful business
or you can have somebody with little to
no qualifications yet they have
incredible results and work with some
inspiring Titans and have been featured
in multiple media Outlets I mean who are
you going to be more inclined to work
with
more likely the latter and and so it's
important to focus on the results that
you can get and over time that speaks
for itself
okay
so would love to talk more about the
book in a sec but I guess one kind of
final strand I wanted to go down was
[Music]
um
let's say someone's listening to this
and thinking oh quite fancy myself
becoming a coach
um
and maybe they're I don't know working a
normal job whether they're a student or
something
um actually yeah let's say they're
working a normal job and they don't
particularly enjoy the job and they're
like you know this coaching thing seems
pretty good but realistically they're
looking at it as like oh you're saying I
can make money by just asking people's
questions something that's something
that sounds fun
um let's say I'm in that position where
I've got my day job and I like the idea
of being a coach on the side to make a
bit of money and potentially quit my job
one day what would be the next action
steps and would you recommend this as a
path to go down
well with regards to the question of
what I recommend it as a path to go down
for me the first place is to really
understand why is coaching important to
them because I don't want them to be
doing it just because they saw someone
make a lot of money from it or they saw
it as a glamorous path because as
glamorous as some paths can be there is
always the challenges the setbacks and
the failures that you are going to
experience and so if you're not really
focused on wanting to make something out
of that path you're not going to survive
the setbacks and the challenges you you
will naturally face on the journey and
so for me the first places to understand
how important is it for you to become a
coach what is this purpose in embarking
on this journey now if money comes into
it I would then throw the question back
to them and said let's say you've made
all the money you've ever wanted so
let's say money's not an issue now what
would you do with that money because
it's to help them understand that money
is not an end goal it's a means goal
it's it's fuel it's like filling up your
car you know money's like the petrol you
put into your car you've got to know
where you're driving your car to in
order to know how much petrol to put
into it now in order to know how much
money you want to have then you've got
to understand what are you going to use
that money for
otherwise you fall into the Trap of
lottery winners who when they win the
jackpot they end up becoming bankrupt or
in a worse position than they were
before they won the jackpot because they
simply didn't have a purpose for the
money okay and if you don't have a
purpose for money what happens is you
end up just spending it
okay so in my in my case let's say I
this doctor example I've listened to
this podcast I'm thinking oh yes I want
to be a coach and I'm thinking I do like
teaching you know I talk people I taught
students in medical school and that was
quite fun and part of being a doctor is
about being a teacher you know classic
interview answer
um and so I like the idea of teaching
and I like the idea of being able to
help people through asking them
questions and I thought the questions
you asked me to get me started on my
podcast for particularly like well that
was nice that's why I feel like I made
progress there
but realistically I'm also thinking Hmm
my salary is about 33k right now working
60 hours a week could I make an extra
one or two thousand pounds a month
because if I do that I can potentially
save up for a deposit on a house and
then I'll just feel less of a money and
security so I'd be combining this
vague interest that I haven't like oh
you know I think I think I enjoy
teaching I want to make money I thought
this coach stuff sounds pretty
interesting and in my mind I'm also
thinking
realistically that
are you saying that I just need a few
clients who'll pay me some money I mean
like starting a podcast feels really
hard like I'm you know there's no way
it's gonna get big like you know it's
like trying to be a musician or
something it's basically never gonna
work but
could I possibly make one or two
thousand pounds a month by being a coach
so those would be the motivations
floating around for me the first two
errors that I will explore my questions
would be one space and second Focus so
what I mean by space is well let's look
at your week how much space in your diet
would you currently have and how much
would you need to actually give this
some proper dedication
so I would look at your week and say
okay what can you eliminate or what can
you reduce to give yourself some more
oxygen and space to explore this
interest of yours now once we've got
that in place the next part is to
actually get some focus and uh I think
it was Cal Newport the first talked
about Focus being today's IQ he said
that in the past we would measure
people's IQ by how much they knew
nowadays when you and I can go into
Google we can ask Amazon Alexa and get
an answer within seconds it's not about
how much you know now it's about your
ability to focus and so the next
question I would ask is how will you
know that with the space you have over
the next seven days it will have been
active week
and so it's beginning with the end in
mind so now what we're doing is we're
bringing a bit of focus into the space
that we've created
and then now once we've got this put
together we now have some path that
we're working towards because at a high
level if we want to design our life if
we want to design something that is
fulfilling it begins with designing our
dates if we can't design our days how
can we expect to design a life
okay
so
coming coming back to the question of
would you recommend the career path it
sounds like yeah if you want to make
money and you enjoy teaching and you
think you'd use the money to do
something good then definitely it would
be a reasonable I'm all further because
as long as
it's a path that is fulfilling for you
that you are interested in that you're
curious about that plays to your
strengths why not but also not to be
attached to the outcome of it you know I
went to
Kyoto in Japan and there was a beautiful
English statement at one of the temples
and it read be attached to no outcome
and open to everything
now I've tried my best to embody that
principle throughout my entrepreneurial
Journey because I think so many of us
get caught up in outcomes so we'll try
something and if it doesn't work out we
tend to stop and give up but if we can
detach ourselves from outcomes then what
it allows us to do is simply just
experiment and as a second part of the
sentence says be open to everything
very often we're like when I get this
when I get more time when this happens
when I get that qualification then I'll
start when everything is ready but the
fact is will never be 100 ready and if
we're always measuring our success by
outcomes only then it's not going to be
a very enjoyable Journey but actually if
we can focus on who we are becoming
how we are going for our own personal
metamorphosis in the journey that to me
is the greatest reward it's not what you
get but it's who you become in the
process
okay nice
so as I'm going through this path of
learning to become a coach because maybe
the destination I have in mind is like
I'll make an extra couple Grandy a month
um
but it sounds like you're saying I
should also
figure out a way to I guess enjoy the
process and become
the sort of person I want to become
through the Journey rather than being
fixated on like I need to make 2K month
extra definitely because I think if you
focus on enjoying the process if you
start to put healthy discipline systems
in place what happens is that you're
setting yourself up to achieve multiple
outcomes not just one outcome but you
open yourself up to achieve outcomes
that you may not even see possible right
now
I mean if you speak to anyone who's
committed to a journey and I use the
word committed purposefully anyone who's
committed to a journey and played full
out
and has been open to everything they've
often got more than they bargained for
they may have fought at the beginning
it'll be great if I get X and then once
they're committed to the journey they
suddenly got more than just X so now X
becomes small compares to everything
else they're achieving and so that's why
it's important to actually enjoy the
process because when we do that the
rewards will eventually come
I love it yeah like this is something
that I say a lot in our in our YouTuber
Academy on in our course where
there is one view that like oh you gotta
grind Out YouTube for the next two years
and then only then will you have success
and that is true but like my model has
always been that find a way to enjoy the
journey because like you you're so
unlikely to get a measurable successful
outcome in a small amount of time and if
you're a wedded to that then you know
those are the sorts of people that burn
out within like a couple of weeks a
month as realize oh this YouTube thing
is hard and it's not getting any results
but I think what I did well in the early
days was not be attached to an outcome
yeah just focus on the process focus on
the things that I can control one or two
videos a week and focus on making it fun
for myself and have a little bit of
improvement because which was inherently
enjoyable and energizing and then it
almost didn't matter what the outcome
was or what the numbers were because I
knew that I was my my life was being
enriched by the journey yeah I I love
that earlier and I can I can personally
resonate with that because if I look
back at a progress I've made I never
plan to be a speaker I never planned to
write a book but it just shows that you
get more than you bargain for when you
commit to the journey so when I left
employment it was just simple build a
healthy five in coaching practice that
was all I was focused on doing but as I
started to do that and I was playing
with my systems I was building a
learning mindset I was hiring mentors
and coaches before long people said
Simon you should speak at this event and
then oh Simon can we interview for this
media Outlet Simon have you thought
about writing a book and so what happens
is that when you show up at a certain
vibrational frequency what happens is
you begin to attract things into your
life that feel dream like sometimes and
and that means why the journey is so
enjoyable why the journey has to be fun
because what happens is that's where the
magic is
what do you mean by show up at a certain
vibrational frequency sure so what I
mean by that is that when you show up in
the world so whether it's in a
conversation uh whether it's at the
event uh whether it's how you deliver
your business when you vibrate at a
certain way now what I mean by this is
that you show up with a certain energy
yeah and the best way to describe this
is that if you were going to an event to
hear someone speak or to network with
people
you might say to your friends I really
liked this person I can't explain why
but there's something about that person
I really like that's what we're talking
about when we say energy it's a language
that has no words but you and I can feed
it
so when you go to a networking event and
you're deciding who do I speak to who do
I introduce myself to if two people come
up to you you're naturally drawn to one
over the other yeah now you can't
explain it you might just say there's
just something about him or her and
that's what I'm talking about about
vibration frequency and energy when we
show up in a certain way what happens is
that we draw people into our field and
they want to spend time with us they
want to help us they want to see us get
to that next level
hmm how does how does one cultivate
one's own sense of vibrational frequency
slash energy slash Vibes like yeah sure
and this is where we go into how I
describe energy uh so energy in one
sense is this life force that we all
possess so in the Maori culture they
call it Mana in my Chinese culture we
call it Chi if you are founded the Star
Wars film franchise you probably refer
to it as the force so on the one hand it
says life force that we all have but we
don't access enough now in order to
really Elevate the energetic quality of
our field it requires us to look at four
dimensions physical mental emotional and
spiritual
we as a society tend to only focus on
the physical get more sleep get more
rest move your body feed yourself right
yeah but we tend to neglect the other
three often because they're more
invisible the mental emotional spiritual
but once we start addressing those other
three dimensions that's how we begin to
show up with more energy I mean just
imagine this for a moment
with regards to spiritual energy
you are doing something that is aligned
to who you are that allows you to
express your strengths and you feel that
you're in flow most of the time that's
what we call high and spiritual energy
low in spiritual energy is where the
work that you're doing is not aligned to
the work that you want to do and that's
where we have some tension that exists
inside of us and some of us may may
relate to this you know you go into work
on a Monday morning there's this tension
because you're doing work where you feel
you're trapped or you're not able to
express some of those skills that are
still dormant inside of you for so long
emotional energy is how you respond to
what happens in the external world but
also how you relate to yourself and
others now when we can understand the
way we relate to ourselves and others
and we can respond in a healthy way
that's where we begin bending and
shaping our reality
into one that is working for us and not
against us you know in the book earlier
I introduced this word to the audience I
say that we all know about the word
paranoia that is the feeling that
somebody's out to sabotage me I am not
getting that promotion because
somebody's trying to put me down or
spread gossip why is it always me that I
fail and that I I can't get the success
that other people are getting the word I
introduce people to is pronoia pronoia
is this belief that the universe is
conspiring in your favor that life is
working for you and not against you and
the question I give to my audience is
Imagine
where life could be if you embraced
paranoia
where every setback can challenge was
meant to exist to give you a lesson to
serve you in some way so this is all
about emotional energy mental energy is
then our ability to focus and access our
creativity which we all have we're born
innately creative so once we have the
ability to focus on what is most
important and access our creativity we
operate at a far higher energetic level
so once we begin focusing on these
dimensions that's what I mean by showing
up with more energy hmm
and so the kind of vibe that someone
would have if they have their physical
mental emotional and spiritual energy
like aligned during whatever
will naturally create some sort of X
Factor that makes you feel drawn to them
as a person definitely this person seems
cool definitely I mean even if if we and
if we look at this quote and it just
popped into my head early by Maya
Angelou she said
when people hear you they may forget who
you are they may forget what you say but
they will never forget how you made them
feel and that is talking to energy
because when we walk out of a room and
we've heard someone connect with us at
an emotional level we never forget that
experience
so how does the book come into this like
what is what is the book about
so the book Taps into what I shared
about energy within those four
dimensions it's about how we can
transform the way we live and work by
Transforming Our relationship with
energy and so it's also a journey of of
my own you know from the world of
Finance to what I do today but also what
I've learned from working with my
clients observing success stories around
me and the lesson that I've acquired
along the way
and
it's a it's a stark reminder to people
reading it that when we Embrace that
Eternal student mindset we begin to open
our field to over a billion teachers
around the world that every person has a
story to share and lessons to tell and
if we're humble enough to operate from
that perspective
life can be so enjoyable I mean we're
learning machines we we fully Embrace
that white bot mentality and we become
aware that there is so much that is
possible
okay
so let's
let's take things back to my genie dog
for example and I've got my thing in the
calendar to do the podcast or maybe and
maybe I'm sort of thinking oh this coach
thing sounds kind of cool
um
as you describe the energy thing I'm
thinking yeah I feel like
I'm probably low on spiritual energy
because the thing that I'm doing in my
day in my day job feels like this this
is tension between what I think I want
and what I think my strengths are
I.E learning and teaching and stuff and
like what I'm actually doing are you
being an admin monkey broadly
I think physical health-wise
probably don't get enough sleep
um probably you know because I take away
on the way home from work from the
McDonald's drive-through uh I don't take
my health very seriously that's actually
what I do
um mentally yeah I think I think I can
focus reasonably well and emotional uh
I think I respond to people reasonably
well but I guess I I see I can see a big
gap in physical and spiritual is is that
how yeah so that would be a good place
to start because awareness is the most
important place to start I often say
that we we can't have self-development
without self-awareness because you can't
change what you're not aware of and so
once we've got an idea within those four
dimensions well what is giving me energy
what is draining me of energy then the
next thing I would say is then given
what you shared with me that you would
like to do or what could be improved if
you were to pick just one of the things
that you shared with me which one of
those things that if you were to give
attention to it would have the greatest
impact on all the other areas for you
I mean I think if I could magically make
my job feel more in alignment with
myself then that would have a big
knock-on effect but I feel like I'm kind
of stuck in this job for the next at
least for the next two years so that
almost seems like a non-starter unless
I'm unless there's something I can do to
change that
so what is in your control that you can
do
hmm
I mean I can definitely stop eating take
away from the McDonald's drive through
every day I can definitely take my sleep
a bit more seriously uh go to bed
because I know I have to wake up early
to get to work at like 6 a.m but that
means I could it is in my control to
sleep at 10 and get eight hours of sleep
rather than to take my phone into bed
with me and like scroll Twitter for an
hour and then feel like bleary eyed the
next morning yeah that's definitely in
my control hmm so when will you begin
sleeping at that time so you can wake up
less bleary-eyed and not scrolling on
your phones and waking up with low
energy you know what tonight I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna sleep at 10 because I
know I have to wake up at six tomorrow
fantastic well let's touch base some
more and I look forward to hearing how
much energy you have when you wake up
with a full night's sleep
nice
it'll it'll it'll come together
um yeah I think I think this is great
like
I find that even with
so much of coaching is
just like asking asking the questions
and just providing a little bit of a
prod of accountability yeah
and people kind of know what the answer
is like we all do yeah and and the thing
is we know what the answers are deep
inside of us but
for whatever reason and it's different
for each of us we're afraid to take the
steps forward
and sometimes it's just putting things
in A New Perspective shifting our mind
in a certain way to get those aha
moments that will be the prodders you
say for us to take action okay you know
talking with skepticism I remember I was
invited to a company over in Canary
Wharf to to do a talk and
at the end of the event one of these
managers come comes up to me and you
know these managers didn't have to come
they just kind of went along because it
was hosted in the building and he said
to me Simon what you said makes a lot of
sense I can hear what you're saying
um but why is it important why should I
listen to what you shared uh what is
incentive for me to to apply this to my
daily life
and the question I asked him
forced him to pause and to reflect and
that's one of the purpose behind good
questions I simply said to him
when was the last time you felt truly
happy
and he had to pause
because it's a sort of question we don't
really reflect on often
and it paused
he paused because he had to think about
that question a lot which told me a lot
of things first thing it told me is that
maybe he wasn't happy right now the fact
that he had to go and think about it and
he said
you know what Simon it's interesting
that question
I'm just realizing as you ask me that
question some of the cars I've bought
some of the Investments I've made
they've been great for a while
but I don't think they really make me
happy
and the question is quite challenging
because
I think it's been a long while since I
have felt truly happy
and literally the question I asked next
is it was as simple as what does that
tell you
and that's because he already knows what
it is telling him sometimes we just have
to verbalize it in order to bring to our
awareness of where we are and where we
actually want to be
and so asking those questions at the
moment really helped to shift
his mind from one that was skeptical to
one that was interested
to what could be
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been able
paying customer of wework for the last
two years now I discovered it during you
know when the pandemic was in the on the
verge of being lifted and I spent like
the whole year just sort of sitting in
my room making YouTube videos but then I
discovered wework and I was a member of
me and Angus my team members we were
members of the wework in Cambridge and
they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all-access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I'd get some free coffee from there I'll
get a few snacks and it's just such a
great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being in an environment
almost like a library but kind of nicer
because there's like a little bit of
soft music in the background and there's
other kind of startup Bros and creators
and stuff in in there as well and it's
just my absolute favorite co-working
space of all time it's super easy to
book a desk or book a conference room
using the app and it's a great place to
meet up with team members if you're
going to collaborate and you'll live in
different places they've got unlimited
tea and coffee and herbal teas and
drinks on tap and they've also got
various kind of after work events that
happen like happy hours and yoga and a
few other exercise type things and you
can also take in guests so often when
guests will come over to visit I'll say
hey let's pop into wework and we'll just
work from there for the whole day and
then we'll go out for dinner sometime in
the evening anyway if you're looking for
a co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend we work like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 of your first booking so thank you so
much wework for sponsoring this episode
let's take another couple of examples
I'm just like this is this is great I
just love how you're responding to all
of like I'm I'm I'm trying I'm trying to
be a bit of a Dicker like to be like oh
come on I'm coaching and then you're
let's just ask and I'm like oh you're
right that's a good question and then
I'm really it's like and even even
though like I'm sort of in a way role
playing a character where there's not a
thing I'm I'm sort of at the same time
feeling like oh that's a really
good question I shouldn't think about
that in my own life as well
um
so one thing that
and now I'm kind of speaking completely
personally one thing that I struggle
with is taking my physical health more
seriously in my mind I have this idea of
like oh it'd be cool to be a bit more
ripped it'd be cool to get maybe six
pack abs but like uh I I end up eating
takeaway quite a lot and
I think my health at the moment is like
fine like it could be better but it's
like Shrine and I'm not sure how much I
care about the six-pack abs versus but
like I know that like I should care
about my physical health and you how how
should how would yeah if if yeah well
first of all based on what you showed
earlier if it's only for the six pack
abs and yeah the muscle look uh that's
not going to be sufficient uh you and I
probably know that's not going to be
sufficient enough motivation uh to keep
you consistent because everybody that
starts their New Year's resolution with
I want to get fitter I want to lose
weight I'm going to get six pack abs you
know what happens you know they sign up
to the gym three four months later
they're using it far less than they ever
did and by the time we get to September
October they may be using it once once a
week twice a week if that and and so we
stop being consistent because
what we know at a high level is that
there's no such thing as overnight
success there's only over time success
and so in order to play the long game
and be consistent in having that healthy
habit we've got to have a purpose for it
and and this is tied in with the concept
of living with intention what is your
purpose to get fit
why is it important to have a healthy
lifestyle now until you have a reason to
have a healthy lifestyle
you're not gonna maintain that
consistency so for me at the beginning
just to give you some background on how
I've maintained my healthy lifestyle at
the beginning it was simply because I
knew I was going to get married in in
about 10 months and I had just ordered a
tailor-made suit and I I could lose
weight but I couldn't gain weight
otherwise I would have to buy another
suit and so that was my initial purpose
was that if I embrace a healthy
lifestyle I could fit in the suit and I
wouldn't have to worry about getting
another one now once I started to get
into the routine after the wedding it
just became part of my lifestyle and
then another motivation kicked in later
when I became a parent is that
I then wanted to live a long life so I
could see my child grow up go to school
go to college experience life go through
their own personal development and in
order to do that suddenly living a
healthy life became a core to living a
long life
and also because bringing to the mix the
fact that I I lost my mom when I was 17.
that showed me how fragile life was and
I didn't want something that was in my
control I.E physical health to be a
factor why I could not live a long life
if it's in my control I wanted to make
sure that I could address it to the best
of my ability and now that became a
purpose for living a healthy lifestyle
so that I could live a long life with my
wife and I could be there for my
children when they grow up that became
something powerful enough to make going
to the gym going running outside going
swimming tiny in comparison to the
rewards that I would get hmm so is it
about like
essentially maxing out our motivation to
want to do the thing it's it's to have a
reason to do it okay if you don't have a
sufficient reason to do something you're
not going to keep it up and and you have
to have a reason to do something
the more
important the reason and the more
personal the reason the more you're
going to keep at it
um
so my thing of like it'll be cool to get
six-pack abs because like maybe I can
like I don't know become a gym shark
athlete I I I I don't actually care
about that it's not a thing that
resonates like that's emotionally moved
it's just and it would be kind of cool
and then I can post a topless pick on it
exactly and I think you've kind of
answered your question Ali you said it's
not something you care about yeah and so
my challenge to you would be to find
something you care about in which that
plays a role in whatever you care about
okay
so let's say on the physical health
front like I love playing squash tennis
badminton and I don't do a lot of that
right now because in my mind I'm sort of
thinking but I wanna I wanna get big
for some reason and I'm thinking like
well uh squash badminton I mean like I
should probably just do weights and
stuff
um but actually the thing I enjoy is
playing squash with friends and doing
like
potentially even hosting like a five or
seven football night with some friends
or like doing like a little like weekly
badminton get together and that would be
super fun because it's a sport that I
enjoy and it's socializing whereas right
now it's like you know I have our
session with my personal trainer this
evening and I'm not looking forward to
it I know it's gonna be a bit Grim yeah
I'm gonna
say something it's interesting because
what you shared I'm going to reflect
back to you you said that
it'll be more fun if I did the squash
and organize the football it's very
social and I noticed you got quite
excited sharing that but then when it
came to the personal trainer your tone
dropped and he said Ah that's Graham I'm
not really looking forward to it yeah
and you and I know we spoke about this
before that in order to actually be
disciplined with a process it's got to
be fun and enjoyable and so it sounds
like you're going against what is
actually fun and enjoyable for you yeah
to do something
which maybe you don't care so much about
hmm
which is the getting big Jim shark
athlete the show the body off yeah but
actually what brings you more fun and
enjoyment is doing the squash and
spending time with friends playing
fighter side football whatever is that
that you were mentioning just now
that's telling isn't hmm
yeah
why am I holding on to this six pack
weird and the thing is is there's never
one route to get to
a goal that is common amongst amongst
many of us uh that there's a case study
I share in the book about an athlete
called Sophie Radcliffe she hated the
gym she never considered herself a
natural athlete and so instead what she
did is she went Outdoors she signed
herself up to challenges such as
triathlons cycling challenges climbing
mountains and and these sort of things
and she found so much joy and
fulfillment from there that actually her
brand is just catapulted to the next
level and she's been partnering with the
likes of U.S staff and BBC and all these
other brands who have followed her in
her travels to as far as Malaysia to
Europe to America to cycling challenges
she has taken on but all of these things
are Outdoors that outside of the gym but
they make her feel alive and it's what
she finds fun doing nice
we talked a little bit earlier about
you know if you want to stay disciplined
with something it's important to find a
way to make it enjoyable to enjoy the
process
um
I very much Vibe with that but it
strikes me that it's it's quite a
privileged position to to be in because
a lot of people have to do things that
they don't necessarily find fun or
particularly want to do any student that
is like I want I know I want to be a
doctor but to get there I know I have to
grind out these random subjects I
actually don't care about because I know
it's a prerequisite or someone who's
working a job that might not necessarily
enjoy because they have to pay the bills
how do we approach that how would you
how would you be approaching that kind
of thing sure well first of all I think
there's there's two camps to what you
shared on the one hand it's what is that
thing you want actually what you want
because if the steps required to get
there isn't something that excites you
is that really what you want then
because whenever you embark on a path
you are going to have to go things that
you don't you have to go through doing
things you don't want to do
the second Camp is you might still like
the destination but you might not like
that process and you want to get
creative so I think there's two camps
the first question is is there actually
something you want to do if you don't
like the journey the second is if you do
really like the outcome how can you
change the journey okay and now that's
where we can get a bit creative if you
look up and I'm going to use a cooking
world as an example because there are
some great case studies there if you
look at Heston Blumenthal he has become
one of the most well-known chefs in the
world he's become a TV personality but
yet
the guy has received no formal training
he learned by himself how to cook and he
ended up coming up with his own style of
cooking and that's what he became known
for so he bypassed what many would have
had to take years to qualify in order to
be to have become the chef that they
want to be but Hassan took a very
different approach if we look at another
case study in the book that I wrote here
Kylie flavelle is a woman who I referred
to in this case study she moved from
Australia to Italy
and she couldn't afford to pay a video
production company to put together his
YouTube videos she wanted to create her
own travel show where she would travel
the world and interview local
communities so she hopped onto YouTube
and she learned everything there was to
know about editing distribution
production recording directing and
producing and she became a one-woman
media company and has grown her YouTube
channel massively since she first
started and has partnered with some of
the world's most well-known brands so
she bypass the fact again she had to go
to a school or to learn from people how
to film and to get qualifications so I
think if it's something you really want
to do is
if you don't like the process to get
there
how can you be a bit more creative in
arriving at the same destination
because as I mentioned earlier there's
never just one way
we are
quickly conditioned to think there is
only one way just as I was when I grew
up I had to go to a good school get top
grades go to a good University in order
to get a good job
but actually today you can still get a
good job by not going through the same
process so how do you think a little
different in achieving the same aims
Okay cool so let's say I am
yeah thinking cool
a I want to get a coach myself and
that's you know I'll do some Googling
I'll find someone maybe see if I've got
any one of my network has some
recommendations
and I'm also thinking I like this idea
of becoming a coach like what is the
playbook for becoming a coach like what
what
like let's say a friend of yours would
be like right someone I want to become a
coach uh what are the next steps that
you should take sure well
I can only reference my own experience
uh the first I would always say is to
look at learning the skill of coaching
yeah because
if you just jump straight into it you
will quickly be found out that you don't
have the relevant experience or
qualifications I would first say learn
about the skill of coaching either by
signing up to
one of these courses where you can learn
about the skill signing up for
qualification or shadowing and learning
from people who have done it for years
that would be my first step second
as with anything you know if you want to
become a writer you write if you want to
speak you speak if you want to coach
coach so get out there and start
coaching people for free at the
beginning start building up that
experience because what happens when you
start coaching people is that gives you
exposure yeah to different people from
different backgrounds different life
situations different goals different
aims so what happens is the more people
you coach through the way that you speak
for the way that you have these
conversations
the more knowledge and wisdom you have
when it comes to coaching people that
eventually pay you hmm
and so how would you go about finding
these three clients would you say to
your friends hey I'm going to be a code
life coach do you want to sign up or
definitely I would say as with any
business when you first start tap your
network tap your network at the
beginning when I first started I just
reached out to a few trusted friends and
said I am looking to start my coaching
business soon and in order to build that
experience I'm looking for free people
who would like to be coached by me for
the next six months at zero cost in
exchange for a testimonial and feedback
that's exactly how I started now people
love things for free especially when
they can get to experience something
they've not had been exposed to before
that's exactly how I started and
if it didn't go well nothing to lose
they haven't paid me this is not public
this is a very private conversation if
it did go well chances that they would
refer me to their Network they would
write a glowing testimonial and so those
things will lead to my next clients and
my next clients
nice
and I guess so the the other day I'm I'm
I met someone who recognized me in the
station and you know she said that yeah
I should be a bit in medicine for 14
years and was leaving to become a coach
and was doing a coaching qualification
and we grabbed breakfast a couple days
later and
um she was doing a lot of like I had had
was doing a qualification and therefore
through that found a bunch of free
people that that she was coaching and I
was sort of challenging her and why she
wasn't charging for the thing just yet
she said oh yeah I need to wait another
six months until my qualification
finishes I was like okay cool what then
and then she was like oh well you know
then I need to build my build my brands
on my website like you know organic
marketing content marketing
I was like I mean what's stopping you
from trying to make the sale from
charging charging the money and then
there was a lot of like emotional
barriers around like the fear of
charging money for a thing
um how did you get a like how or what
was your experience of dealing with like
because anytime someone sells something
especially selling a service something
that feels as personal as coaching it
always feels like there's a bit of like
a response to the selling of the thing
again I think when we have a bit of uh
tension inside when we're selling
something
my experience tells me is that because
you don't believe it in it enough you
don't believe in what you have to offer
enough I mean if you really believe that
what you are offering whether it's a
product or whether it is a service has
values to
the person's life yeah it is easy to
sell yeah it is easy to sell because
you're coming from a place of I know
this can have an impact on your life I
know that if we were to work together I
don't know what the outcomes would be
but I know you will be in a very
different place 12 months from now
now if you truly believe that it comes
across the selling becomes easy now of
course it is challenging at the
beginning uh you know
when I had the opportunity to meet my
first CEO client of a major business
I had imposter syndrome I was like am I
ready to work with someone at that level
and then I realized that in order to
show up and served them in a powerful
way I had to act in the present as the
person that I wanted to be tomorrow
and that really helped to build that
belief to see that I was ready for what
was coming but also I was ready to have
those conversations
yeah it strikes me that this is this
thing of not believing in your own your
own product almost is a again just to
use the YouTube example is is an issue I
see with a lot of YouTuber friends and I
have this a lot myself sometimes which
is where there's a bit of internal
tension around making a video because
like is this video actually good enough
I'm not sure if this is if this is
actually going to be valuable
um but what I find you know as Austin
Cleon writes about is that you know
what's like usually we are our own worst
critics and
the bar that we have for something that
we put out is generally different to the
bar that the audience has and I could
put out something that I potentially
think is bad but could actually be
really helpful to 10 000 people yeah
possibly not 10 million people but hey
whatever but at least 10 000 people
would find it useful and so in in that
sense what what do you think is this
balance between
that internal feeling that I might have
of like my product isn't good enough I
feel a bit weird about it versus the
fact that even in its bad state it could
well be quite useful to someone and it
goes back to this idea of being attached
to an outcome and open to everything is
that when we're detached from the
outcome we're just focusing the process
we get the first video out then we
simply step back and we ask ourselves
one what went well and two what could be
better next time and then we do the next
video ask yourself the same question do
the next video ask yourself the same
question so what we're focusing on is
less the outcome from each video but
more the improvement from video to video
and that's what's most important because
as you said you can put out what you
think is a bit of bad content but
actually people lap it up you could put
out a bit of good content that you think
should do really well but just doesn't
do as great as you think and it's the
same thing with my book you know I wrote
this book and there's Parts a book I
think are really good that people are
going to really enjoy and parts that I
think
are not as good as some other parts but
when the book is out in in the open I
suddenly get feedback and I'm seeing
some people highlighting pages that I
felt weren't as good as I thought it was
and suddenly they found it really good
and so I think it shows us that you
can't always predict people's feedback
and opinion and Views before you put a
piece of content out and it is why again
the process is so important focus on the
Improvement rather than the quality of
every video because if you let quality
be your benchmark especially when you're
just starting you're going to give up
you can say I don't have this camera I
don't have these resources I don't have
this team well of course nobody had that
when they first started but you've got
to start somewhere
I love that yeah yeah I had a I had a
moment in it was in one of our YouTuber
Academy cohorts where someone said like
you know they built the like the most
expensive package and they were like oh
you know I just want to say you've
really changed my life that video that
he put out on how to how to beat
imposter syndrome that that video really
resonated with me
and I was so surprised because that was
one of the worst performing videos on
the channel I was like what and she was
like yeah you know it's because of that
video that I started my YouTube channel
and I you know got a promotion at work
because I realized that I could be
impostor Center in this way and that's
why I've signed up to your course and I
was just like completely flawed because
in my mind that was a dud video it was
awful it was funny because you mentioned
an awesome Cleon quote earlier and
another awesome clown quote just came up
in my head which is we find our voice by
using our voice and that is the process
of iteration you know the more you use
your voice the more you can find what
your voice is
you're not going to find it by
overthinking on the sidelines to the
point of it being too curated that
you've kind of lost your voice in it
you've just gotta as as Seth Godin says
ship it just keep shipping shipping
shipping eventually you find out what
your voice is
I love it
Simon thank you so much this has been
absolutely wonderful I feel like I came
into this thinking like okay right this
this coaching thing is should have
surely surely like you and it's weird
because like I've had coaches basically
non-stop for the last like three years
and it's been one of the most freaking
incredible Roi positive Investments of
my life and actually like three days ago
started working with I mean the most
expensive coach I've ever worked with is
like a CEO coach and immediately in like
session number one it just made so many
breakthroughs and he wasn't even telling
me much he was just asking the right
questions like somehow it's so
incredibly valuable and even though I
was trying to I was trying to give you a
hard time I just thought the way you
responded to everything which is so
great and you have this such this such
like warm and like Zen energy about you
it's just like unflappable just chill
and just like asking such good questions
that really strike out oh my God yeah
you're right that's so true um so thank
you so much for being so gracious with
your time thank you so much for having
me ali um any final asks for the
audience anyone who might be watching or
listening to this
a final forward and it's one that I
share in chapter two of my book which is
in April 2020 my wife and I gave birth
to our first child just a few days after
the country went into his first lockdown
and that process reminded me of
something that we so often forget which
is that we are all a miracle I mean the
fact that we were born is a miracle
event in itself
we have won the greatest lottery ticket
there is going I mean people dream about
winning the jackpot in the National
Regional Lottery we literally have won
the greatest jackpot there is going the
lottery of life and the question I love
to leave the audience with is this
what are you going to do with that
winning ticket of yours
I love it Clayman thank you so much
thank you all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye